いいね、週末感があるね
今日はみんなとのんびりお話をしよう！
ちょっとみんなのセンスを
今日は聞いてみようと思います
はい、というわけで
今からTwitterの方で
募集をかけます
SkypeIDです！通話待ってます！
みなさんのセンスで僕を笑わせてください...
これでいいだろ
これで...OK!
つぶやいてしまった
はい今こういう感じで
僕のSkypeIDを晒してしまいました
これで皆さんが僕にSkype～で
電話をかけてくるという訳でございます。
何かねツイキャスでですね、
コラボっていう機能があるんだけどぉ
もう何かね見に来る人が多すぎて
【着信音】
あ、えっもう来たよ もう来たよ
もう来たよ
【着信音】
あれ？
視) こんにちは
あ、こぉんにちは
視) あ！こんにちは
ちょっと待ってねx1
ちょっと待ってねx2
視) はい
ちょとま、ちょっと待ってねx1
ちょとま、ちょっと待ってねx2
ヤバかかりすぎててヤバい
ちょ待て
ちょ待て。
待って
ちょっと待て待て待て
待って待って待ってww
ちょ舐めてた舐めてた
視) これかかってますか？
かかってるバッチリかかってるよ
視) えぇっ！？
ちょとw待ってねw！！
視) はいw
ちょっと一回落ち着きますね
ちょっと待って
待って待って
これヤバいヤバいどうしようどうしよう
こんなにかかるとは思わなかった
着信通話の音とかなくそう
ヤバいもう駄目だ
スカイプが動かなくなっちゃってる
設定動いて！
あ、駄目だ
Skype。
待って待ってマジヤベえ
やらかした完全にやらかした俺。待って。
えーとこの通知音がヤベえな待ってヤバい。
マジヤベ、マジヤバい、マジヤベ、マジヤベ、マジヤベっス
これ完～全に舐めてた
待ってこれパソコン落ちるんじゃね？
ダメだ動かなくなっちゃった
待ってヤバい。
ちと、分かった皆ありがとう
皆ありがとう皆ありがとね！
本当に。
ちょと待てwww
はーぁ
待ってマジでどうすれば良い、こういう時は
はぁふ、す、ふ、す、ふ、す、ふ、す、ふ、す
ヤバい油断してた
まあそりゃそうだよね
ちょっと待って一回Skypeをちゃんとしましょう
オーディオ設定でいけるはず
待って待ってヤバい
始また始また始また
すごいな
もうやばいな、スロットル並みに回転してるね
フルスロットルだぜ
イェイ↑
ちょっと待って待って待て
音をとりあえずこの...音をなくそう
待ってこのピースしてる俺がちょっと...
いらねぇ
みんなぁ、ごめんね
ごめんみんな
パソコンが動かないよ
設定だけでもいいから変えないと
パソコンが本当に死ぬ
押せないよね？だって
もう一回落ち着いて
ちょっと起動してみましょう
通知音さえなくせば
みんなと会話できるから
スカイプを起動した瞬間に
いかに通知音をなくせるかが
ポイントです
おかしいな...あ！
やばい始まった始まった
待って待って待って
とりあえずダイヤルパッドを消して
あ、もうダイヤルパッドも
消せない感じね...
待って
どうしよ、どうしよ、どうしよ、どうしよ
本当に動かないんだけど
何にも反応しないよ？
ほらもう応答しない
どうすればいい？
いや待って
マジでどうすればいい？
通知音さえ
トゥルルットゥルーさえ
なくせば
なんとかなるとは思うんですけど
みなさーん
ごめんね
ちょっとSkypeでも
耐えれなかったみたいだ
ツイキャスのコラボキャスもダメだし
Skypeでも話せないってなると
俺はどうやってみんなと話せばいいの？
あはっあはぁ...(泣)
誰かぁ助けて...
みんなとお話ししたいよー
したいけど...
どうしようどうしようどうしよう
どうすればいいんだろう？
けど俺にできることなんてないよ
応答しないもんね
あ、一回で良いからさぁ
あの、設定画面まで行けたら
俺の勝ちなんだよ多分。
設定画面に行く前に猛攻撃を避けて、
上手いこと設定で通知音を止める。
そうすれば多分誰かしらと電話が出来ると思うんで。
ほらほら、起動に時間がかかる来たよ～
うわヤベえ
1540件の新しい通知だ。
はっw
どうだ！
いけるか
駄目だ動かねえ！
うわもう駄目だ何も出来ねえや
本当に何も出来ない。
え、MacProでしょぉ？
MacProの最高スペックだよ？
これヤバいなあ
対策を取らないと
しくった。
今回のミスは、先に通知音を
通話音を無くしておけば良かった。
本当申し訳ない
も、こういう企画モノみたいになっちゃってるね
一息してからもう一回Skype起動してみましょう。
よし、起動します。
来た来た来た
おっ
おっ！
止まってる？
マジ止まってるっぽくね？これ
あっ...あっ！
ヤバもう2057件の新しい通知
アカウント変えなきゃいけねえなこれ多分。
ムリだもーん
通話に...出る事ももうできない感じなんで。
まま。
まぁ僕のせいですよ。
ぼ、僕が悪いですよ。
もう言い出した僕が悪いですけどぉ、
ッス――ゥ
すごいね。
んねぇもう皆とお話ししたいよぉ～
お話しさせてぇ～
今だ。
祈祷中...
～悲しみのオルガン～
ぉぉぉーーーーーーぉぉぉぉぅぅぅ↓
ハッ。
はい今回のSkype企画、
大成k